[Music]
okay
so this is my review of your honor
episode seven now this
episode is now revealing my concerns
about this being a 10 episode
series i really think with a lot of
shows like this
they perform better when they're aimed
to be seven or eight episodes i think
10 always guarantees a lot of filler or
stuff that could just be chopped down
and this episode was
filled with scenes that could have been
a little tighter there's three scenes
that stood out to me
that had this feeling where you'd start
to feel it
drag and that is where we got a couple
sequences of michael
out on the boat taking care of putting
trevor's body in the water through this
anchor
which just seemed a lot of screen time
to get to that
point this also happens the scene with
lee when she actually gets let go by her
boss that just felt two minutes too long
and even the scene with nancy costello
with carlo where she's
trying to scare him into confessing
early just felt a little
too long trying to make it so
melodramatic
with intimidating him about what
happened to people been executed but it
was
just going for a really long time
and the problem with scenes like this it
takes away from the core
of the story the characters were
attached to and the plot lines i've
developed that we're most interested in
where it's kind of just getting bogged
down in little stories that
all of a sudden they're giving a lot of
weight and time to and
as a result there's some weird things
where again i bring this up the inhaler
the dna we're waiting for to come back
that it's adam's now it's been
definitely been past three days and they
said it was going to come back in three
days that's been long forgotten
and the teacher that adam was sleeping
with
she found out about what really happened
and hasn't been in the show now
feels like eternity so it's already
setting up for their returned it might
feel like a cheat
that they'll just be bought in when they
conveniently help the plot in need of a
twist
and that also is the feeling of grandma
here where she's at the dinner at the
end but she had this whole episode and
that she's also kind of drifted apart
so by trying to get all these characters
in
and then now going back to giving nancy
a lot of screen time and carlo
and unnecessarily showing us trevor
drowning for such a long time and
getting that
developed can take away from characters
and plot lines that we were grinding our
teeth into now what i also thought was
funny was
when michael goes out to sea with
jimmy's right hand man here
and they're getting rid of trevor and
they cut to when they're actually out on
this boat brian cranston's hair is full
on gray and a lot longer than we last
saw it and the rest of the episode his
hair will be
like gandalf the gray and i mean this
has to be a result of
the show was put on pause with filming
because of covid and then they returned
to filming and i'm guessing
once we saw the scenes where they were
out on c and everything after was filmed
once kovit had began
in their second slate and someone in the
costume department and makeup forgot to
get some more just for men for brian
cranston
and at this point in the game already
seven episodes into this story that's
very long because each episode is about
an
hour i don't understand why we're
getting so much focus even on
the side plot with joey who is carlo's
right-hand man and has the bag of heroin
and at this point in the game like is
this really necessary to even
keep bringing up i'm not really sure we
don't have a lot of time left now to
wrap up stories that were set up in
episode two
and three and now introducing other
conflicts now a scene i did like in this
episode was at the docks when michael
faces jimmy
and they're calling each other out on
their hypocrisy and
pretty much how terrible each of them
are and this episode does a good job of
highlighting that and it was good even
here michael addressed jimmy about
killing kofi's family but
you see that they just justify and only
focus on what's
been wrong to them and losing a family
member and just having innocence pay the
price
and that works well because michael's
story here it's
very good character arc for him and
where he's gone in a changed man
and it comes all the way around to him
actually
setting up this dui of the judge who got
carlos case
it's really just crazy that he got her
arrested and i like they timed it where
he says i love you to lee when he sees
his plan worked and then he goes
he has a birthday surprise but
effectively he's reminded about
what he's really done when django spits
up trevor's brain and to
avoid any confusion because it was
confusing even on my part but i'm
assuming that was trevor's
like a piece of brain that was not
noticed by michael on his clothes that
adam
noticed in the kitchen because we saw
trevor's back of head was bashed in they
did one shot where it looked like goo
was coming out but of course adam fed
the dog
the brain back because again adam can't
do anything right i love just picking on
adam's character i get a thrill out of
it oh and very
cringe-worthy writing here was in the
first courtroom scene
the prosecuting attorney says f you
f you up the ass what the hell was that
i always like to point out scenes like
this because i just wonder on set like
someone has to just say stop retweet
that line
do it over anything it's so
bad and it's like who is this cartoon
character that is this prosecuting
attorney that they just
introduced so strange so we can see
though nancy's catching on to this
corrupt
cop who's got a relationship with the
lawyer all
in cahoots with the baxters and gina
asking for nancy's name i
think we're gonna see nancy is gonna be
the big person here in michael's life
who
probably pays the price in one way
probably death
because they're setting up she's gonna
find out a little too much and gina
asking her name scares me a lot but i
don't even have much to talk about
this episode was a very thin episode it
was a very forgettable episode but it
also
slows down the momentum that was built
in the last episode i understand there's
episodes to catch your breath
but in that catching of the breath we
also feel a lot of wasted time and not
feeling like everything is necessary to
get to our ultimate goal
of our payoffs hopefully in the end and
answering some questions from the
beginning while they're actually
introducing more questions especially in
this joey's storyline with carlo
and the heroine and it just feels a
little bit late in the game to start
making this
important so this was my least favorite
episode of the season i'm gonna give
this one a 7.7
i don't know how exciting they can still
keep this up now i hope it didn't
peak that when jimmy found out about
michael that was the moment we've been
waiting for and then now we're kind of
just gonna hit
maybe a little bit of a lull but i hope
it picks up the pace again
and gets us hooked into what could
happen now with michael and jimmy
and maybe get adam now closer to
squealing about what really
happened we shall see let me know down
below you saw this episode i love to
hear your thoughts i read every comment
and try to respond to as many as i can
please make sure to subscribe so you
don't miss one of my reviews of your
honor i'm also reviewing
the show serving at the moment so you're
gonna check those out as well and if you
like what i do here i'd really
appreciate a two dollar monthly donation
you could commit to
there's a paypal link down below that
will give me
the means necessary to start doing this
full time and make more videos for you
guys
and please follow me at steve varley
show on twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time